[Musique]
le travail c'est la liberté
le travail c'est l'égalité des chances
le travail c'est la promotion sociale
le travail c'est le respect c'est la
dignité c'est la citoyenneté
mes chers compatriotes la crise morale
française porte un nom c'est la crise du
travail le travail n'est pas assez
respecter le travail n'est pas assez
récompensé le travail n'est pas assez
considéré
je ne peux pas accepter une société où
il ya des milliers d'offres d'emploi qui
ne sont pas satisfaites
je ne peux pas accepter une société ou
un assisté est à la fin du mois
davantage que celui qui travaille je
propose que l'on ne puisse pas refuser
plus de deux offres d'emploi c'est pas
normal d'être dans un pays où il ya plus
de 2 millions de chômeurs avec les
offres d'emploi et les métiers en crise
pas demandeur
[Musique]
tous ceux qui voudront travailler
davantage pour gagner davantage pourront
le faire ses taux que celui qui est au
smic et qui travaillent 50 minutes de
plus par jour peut espérer 15%
d'augmentation de son pouvoir d'achat
je dis aux entreprises que sur les
heures supplémentaires elles ne paieront
pas de charge et jeudi aux salariés que
sur les heures supplémentaires ils ne
payeront pas d'impôts on augmentera
ainsi le pouvoir d'achat on mettra du
carburant dans la croissance française
la croissance créera des emplois
les emplois donneront du pouvoir d'achat
nous allons regagner le point de
croissance qu'il ment
[Musique]
mais je veux aller plus loin je veux que
les jeunes qui font des études qui
veulent travailler puissent le faire
sans payer d'impôts je veux que le
retraité qui veut améliorer sa petite
retraite puissent travailler à temps
partiel
en plus de sa retraite je veux que celui
qui veut rester plus longtemps pour
avoir une meilleure retraite puissent le
faire je me mette un terme à ses 5
milliards d'euros dépensés pour obliger
des quinquagénaires encore jeunes qui
ont envie de travailler de partir à la
retraite
travailler plus pour gagner davantage
voilà la solution pour trouver le plein
emploi
je souhaite également mettre la question
du logement au coeur du débat politique
français
je veux que chacun d'entre vous puisse
être propriétaire de son logement à ceux
qui n'ont pas de relations
je veux dire que la garantie la caution
de leur emprunt c'est l'état qui la
donnera à ceux qui ont un patrimoine et
qui veulent le laisser à leurs enfants
je veux dire que je supprimerai les
droits de succession pour la quasi
totalité des français parce que je crois
à la famille parce que je crois au
travail et parce que quand on a
travaillé toute sa vie on a le droit de
transmettre à ses enfants le fruit d'une
vie de travail
je veux faire de vous une france de
propriétaires et aux malades
je veux dire que je n'accepterai pas que
lorsqu'on emprunte on doit passer une
visite médicale et que celui qui est
malade pour emprunter doit payer plus
cher c'est l'état qui cautionnera
l'emprunt de celui qui est malade c'est
ma conception de l'égalité de l'équité
et de la justice sociale
[Musique]
je veux dire un mot de l'euro j'ai voté
pour l'euro nous avons créé la deuxième
monnaie du monde
c'était un choix historique et un choix
utile mais je veux dire aussi qu'on n'a
pas fait l'euro pour que l'euro soit
surévalué et détruisent des emplois en
europe
je poserai la question de la
surévaluation de l'euro qui crée ton de
déficit
chez airbus j'ai toujours choisi
l'europe et je crois en l'europe mais
l'europe je veux qu'elle protège de la
mondialisation
j'aurai une europe qui pas peur de
parler de la préférence communautaire
pour défendre notamment nos agriculteurs
parce qu une france sans ouvrier sans
usines
une france sans paysans sans ruralité
une prendre 100 artisans
ça serait une france appauvri
culturellement économiquement
socialement politiquement
la seule façon de gagner davantage c'est
travailler davantage la seule façon
d'obtenir le plein emploi c'est de
libérer les forces du travail
je veux que la france redevienne le pays
de la création de l'innovation crée des
richesses pour les mettre au service de
tous mes chers compatriotes il n'y a pas
de fatalité ce que les autres ont réussi
nous pouvons réussir ensemble
[Musique]